вам колеги рекомендуємо діяти як народні
депутати України а не зелені кнопочки є
постанова зареєстрована представниками
фракції слуга народу про відкликання
абсолютно безвідповідальної людини яка
щодня дискредитує збройні сили України
яка принижувала наших загиблих партійців
безугла - це антонім захисту нацбезпеки
ви знаєте що таке антонім це не Синонім
це антонім і дуже важливо ще зробити
наступ друзі це буде тільки перший крок
відкликати антонім з посади заступника
голови комітету далі її треба відкликати
самого комітету антонімам не місце в
безпеці і обороні Вони мають бути де
завгодно А наступний крок буде що її
відкличуть із посади депутата і це
зроблять жителі Оболонського району які
не розуміють що зараз відбувається